an independent fda advisory panel meets
today and tomorrow to talk about covid19
booster shots one issue on the agenda
mixing and matching vaccines there is a
new study out with new test data showing
people who got one dose of johnson and
johnson might be better off getting the
other vaccines as a booster
joining us now with more on all this is
dr vivek morthy he's the u.s surgeon
general dr morty thank you for being
here and good morning to you
let's talk about this nih study with the
understanding that you're not part of
the fda panel and that's a whole process
that's going to move forward
people are curious what the results of
the nih study tell them about whether
johnson johnson is worth getting a
second shot of
well good morning to you as well tony
and the data that that is being reported
on this is the kind of data that the fda
is going to be considering in the
advisory committee over the next few
days i would be cautious about it
interpreting on its own right now
because what the fda is going to look at
is a few things including the quality
of the data itself then quality really
has to do with the sample size it has to
do with the strength of the data they're
also going to look at the fact that some
of this is laboratory data which
concerns antibody levels versus clinical
data which is about outcomes and they'll
put that together
ultimately in a recommendation that they
make but the bottom line is what people
need to know is over the next few days
you're going to be hearing a lot of news
from the fda and from the cdc about the
mix and match studies but also about
boosters from moderna and pfizer vaccine
recipients there are four steps to that
process the fda advisory committee meets
then the fda will render a decision the
cdc advisory committee meets then the
cdc will render a decision the advisory
committees provide advice but ultimately
it is the agencies themselves that will
make the final decision
doctor on the subject of advice there
are already people anecdotally who are
going out and mixing and matching
vaccines if one of those people was a
patient of yours what would you tell
them
what i would tell them is number one
sometimes you've got to make
individualized decisions in consultation
with your healthcare provider but we
should generally whenever we can try to
follow the advice of the fda and the cdc
here because they are looking at the
totality of the data and they're looking
not just at efficacy you know is this
actually working but they're looking at
safety as well and so those
considerations have to be part of how we
make our decisions but ultimately people
have questions on mixing and matching
they should talk to their their doctor
about it there might be some reason
people don't want to stick with the
original vaccine they got maybe it has
to do with their reaction they had maybe
there are other considerations but by
and large i would follow the fda and cdc
recommendations on mixing and matching
right now and they are going to render a
final decision on that in the coming
weeks
dr murphy if we're seeing covet cases um
hospitalizations and deaths go down has
the worst been behind us
well i'm i'm an optimist by nature and
i'm cautiously optimistic that the
decline in cases and hospitalizations
that we're seeing
is something that portends more more
good news to come but we've got to be
cautious because we have seen declines
before and then we have seen cases go up
again one thing we've learned though
over this past experience particularly
with the delta wave that we've had over
the past weeks is that the vaccines have
been remarkably effective at keeping
people out of the hospital and saving
their lives we have to take that lesson
and build on it and ensure that we take
the weeks and months ahead to vaccinate
as quickly as possible the over 65
million people who remain unvaccinated
that is our surest pathway to ending the
pandemic and ultimately saving lives
and we want to be on that pathway dr
moorthy thank you very much we
appreciate it